this is new at 4 30 a home burglary is
caught right on camera it's probably one
of our worst your biggest worries when
you leave home for the holidays
certainly mine as we plan for our summer
vacations Andrews now reporter Victoria
Saha speaking to the homeowners who
learned all this the hard way
one Henderson Family had several ring
cameras in place before they left for
vacation but once on vacation they woke
up to several notifications on their
Ring app and they knew someone was
inside their home I had like 12
notifications from that camera and I was
started freaking out Nicholas and
Jennifer Hyatt thought they secured
their home if I would remember to lock
that one little window
he would have not been able to get
inside we aren't identifying the burglar
because Henderson Police have not
arrested or charged the person but the
Hyatt say on Saturday night he jumped
their locked gate and climbed through
their kitchen window the feeling of
powerlessness like like all you can do
is literally just sit there and watch
them the burglar thinking he wouldn't
leave any trace of him took a sponge to
wipe off his fingerprints the hayat say
the burglar was in their house for over
an hour going room to room when they
realized what happened the next morning
they called police but the odd thing is
the hayats tell us earlier in the day
there were children ringing their
doorbell it's something Jonathan Alvarez
a security professional says was likely
set up if they target a house they'll go
and they'll knock on the door and
several times to see if anybody answers
him Oliver I suggests doing a thorough
check of any openings into your house
this window can I can I open it from the
outside think like a criminal when
you're securing your home as for the
Hyatts this incident has left them
feeling like they lost their sense of
security they could have literally just
knocked on our door and we would have
gladly helped them they didn't need to
steal
now Henderson Police say they have
closed the case until they actually get
any new leads that couple though
offering five thousand dollars to
anybody who comes forward who knows who
that burglar is in another simple way to
protect your home according to that
expert is always make it look like
someone is there simply by putting
timers on your lights around your home
make it look like someone's in your
house and it's so easy but it's so smart
so scary to watch it too